on va plus loin avec anniva journaliste
de guerre indépendante bonjour Anne
bonsoir grand reporter face à vous
gauthierry beinsky chroniqueur
international bonjour Gauthier on en est
au 222e jour de guerre en Ukraine et le
moins qu'on puisse dire un siècle le
terrain n'a toujours pas livré son
verdict alors que la Douma le Parlement
russe a ratifié l'annexion des quatre
régions ukrainiennes à l'unanimité sont
même une voix d'abstention la ville de
Liman elle est repassée hier aux mains
des Ukrainiens présentés par les experts
comme un euphorroviaire stratégique vers
l'est la région de louantes et le nord
de celle de Daniels alors que l'armée
ukrainienne maintient aussi la pression
au sud dans la région de Kerson écoutez
ce qu'on dit le secrétaire général de
l'OTAN
cela démontre que les Ukrainiens
progressent ils sont capables de
repousser les forces ruches grâce à leur
courage leur bravoure leurs compétences
mais bien sûr aussi grâce aux armes
fournies par les États-Unis et d'autres
alliés
à un tel démenti à Moscou à pousser
ainsi les rives russes dans leur
retranchements
mais c'est la guerre Raphaël donc dans
les Ukrainiens si vous leur dites ça ils
vont pas comprendre ils font ce qu'ils
ont envie de faire sur le terrain et ce
qu'il réussit à faire et aujourd'hui
clairement l'initiative elle est du côté
ukrainien elle est elle est totalement
du côté ukrainien parce que ils
attaquent finalement là où ils ont
décidé d'attaquer c'est ça la nouveauté
et bien sûr ils sont aidés en cela on
vient de le dire par les armes qu'on
leur fournit mais aussi par le
renseignement militaire le renseignement
militaire américain notamment qui leur
permet de de définir de vérifier de
regarder d'observer où sont finalement
les points faibles une page faible là
ils peuvent attaquer et ils attaquent
véritablement là où c'est faible et donc
ils avancent et aujourd'hui on en est là
on en est à cette deuxième phase je
dirais de la contre-offensive
ukrainienne qui a commencé à la fin de
l'été début septembre et
ce qui est intéressant aujourd'hui c'est
de voir si la mobilisation côté russe va
aboutir à quelque chose mais beaucoup de
spécialistes militaires disent déjà que
cette mobilisation aura du mal à avoir
un effet sur le terrain et s'y est fait
là ça sera pas tout de suite ça sera
dans trois mois et dans trois mois ça
sera peut-être trop tard étant donné
également les conditions météorologiques
comme vous le savez puisque il pleut
beaucoup sur le front et c'est pas bon
pour les blindés et pour les combattants
et dans quel dans effectivement des
temps alors il faudra passer que sur des
routes-gournées on sait très bien que la
guerre c'est pas que des routes
goudronnées et ensuite ça va ça va se
geler donc il va il va forcément y avoir
une espèce de pose sur le terrain
militaire donc les Ukrainiens pour le
moment qui ont la main haute veulent
aller au plus loin combien de temps
Gauthier la poutine peut-il se
satisfaire de voir ses territoires tout
juste des critérus lui échapper oui ça
découle un peu de ce que vient dire ah
mais je sens que la question que vous me
posez c'est peu avantage la réaction sur
les Russes
leur territoire avant d'utiliser donc
une arme nucléaire éventuellement tout
le problème est aussi chimique ou
chimique tout le problème est celui du
rapport de force avec son aile extrême
toute une série de en fait de d'anciens
national bolchevik de l'époque où ce
parti existait et chapeauté par Limonov
tous ces gens là sont là pour pousser au
crime c'est clair vous avez le le le
Bubble télévisuel ça la vie off il dit
mais il faut que par les armes ce qui ne
veulent pas aller au combat bon vous
voyez où on en est mais si je pense que
ce n'est pas encore maintenant qu'on
peut se poser cette question exactement
la question se la posera le jour où il y
aura éventuellement j'en sais rien mais
des mouvements qui sont observables par
l'OTAN par l'ouest par les Américains
qui et qui prouveront qu'on est en train
de mettre en place un dispositif
éventuellement nucléaire c'est-à-dire du
clair tactique bien sur la
recommandation au site de quelqu'un qui
est frappé par l'esprit des Lumières
c'est Randan de Rohff donc le roitelet
tchétché donc voilà c'est qui lui le
recommande depuis ce weekend depuis ce
weekend et donc assez à partir de ce
moment là où on verra parce que ça se
voit par observation satellite et vous
me direz c'est peut-être trop tard une
fois qu'on le voit en même temps c'est
quelque chose qui ne se décide pas du
jour au lendemain c'est quelque chose
qui se fait il y a une chaîne de
commandement et commencer qu'elle est un
peu problématique en ce moment en Russie
ça peut aussi laisser du temps donc
c'est pas vraiment une réponse très
opérationnelle que je vous donne là mais
c'est vrai que Poutine est
partagé entre ses propres affects
aujourd'hui et ce d'une partie de
l'extrême droite russe qui voudrait au
fond qu'il aille plus vite ou défaut
l'éliminer ou le doubler Annie va vous
pensez comme Gauthier que voilà la
qualité du renseignement et le caractère
assez encombrant finalement du nucléaire
fait qu'on ne peut pas le faire de
manière anodine ou masquée oui tout à
fait mais pour ajouter aussi ce que
vient de dire Gauthier par rapport à
Ramzan qui a dit Rohff ce qui est
intéressant c'est que donc comme dit
Gauthier il y a les plus extrémistes que
Vladimir Poutine qui donne de la voix
aujourd'hui mais ce sont des opposants à
Vladimir Poutine des opposants plus
extrémistes mais des opposants quand
même tandis que quand on parle de Ramzan
kadirof ça n'est pas un opposant à
Vladimir Poutine c'est un allié de
Vladimir Poutine et ça c'est nouveau
depuis quelques jours le fait qu'il y
ait des alliés de Vladimir Poutine qui
se permettent de critiquer haut et fort
ce qui est en train de se passer le
cadirov donc critique le fait d'être
général est un incapable etc etc
selon laquelle ces trois enfants qui
sont mineurs 15 14 présent il est
d'accord pour les envoyer au front ce à
quoi quand même je crois que le Kremlin
a répondu que le Kremlin n'en voyait
personne de mineur au front mais donc
émotions ce qui est pas mal pour le
Kremlin quand même biscoff qui est le
porte-parole du Kremlin a dit de par
rapport aux propos de qu'il fallait se
méfier de ses propos qui sont du ressort
de l'émotion mais en même temps en même
temps Gautier il a ménagé cadirof parce
que Kadirov et ça tout le monde le sait
dans ses hautes sphères du kremblin et
celui qui de lui-même si je puis dire
sans attendre la mobilisation à
mobiliser le plus de façon forcenée dans
sa république et qu'aujourd'hui il est
donc justement un petit peu c'est pour
ça qu'il critique peut-être un petit peu
privé de sa marge de manœuvre parce que
la mobilisation finalement l'empêche de
continuer à mobiliser d'ailleurs il a
dit qu'il mobiliserait plus et c'est
dans la République voisine celle du
nuggestan qu'il y a aujourd'hui les plus
fortes contestations on a vu ces
dialogues entre mère et représentant des
de l'ordre qui qui par rapport à cette
mobilisation et ça aussi c'est nouveau
c'est très intéressant je vais essayer
d'être rapide le Daguestan c'est
passionnant parce que précisément
ethniquement ce ne sont pas des Russes
et de quoi s'aperçoivent les Dagueys qui
est proportionnellement ils sont plus
exposés au front que les soldats de la
même manière qu'au début c'était des
gens de bruyiatiques en effet dire et
donc ça veut dire que la grande
fraternité de l'Empire russe elle est
valable que sur le papier puisque en
réalité ça a toujours été ça depuis
l'État au ménage les Slaves par exemple
quand il s'agit d'aller à la guerre et
on envoie au frontières et pas que enfin
tous ceux qui sont non russes et qui et
qui composent la grande mosaïque de des
peuples de la Fédération de Russie Mitry
pescov évoque maintenant à des
consultations des populations dans ces
régions annexées pour en fixer les
frontières oui c'est effectivement Alain
des aspects de la étonnant presque de
l'intervention de Vladimir Poutine lors
de cette célébration de ces annexions
c'est qu'il a il n'a pas précisément il
a dit d'ailleurs ça reste à fixer les
frontières est-ce que d'après vous Anne
si cherchent à se ménager une porte de
sortie un éventuel en jeu de négociation
sur cette question des frontières de ces
de ces territoires annexés
sans doute même dans le discours de
Vladimir Poutine il y a quelques jours
qui était un discours d'une violence
absolument inouïe même selon les
critères déjà de pour Vladimir Poutine
il y avait quand même un mot peu
crédible mais un mot quand même sur la
possibilité du négociation donc c'est
mais c'était dit pratiquement un niveau
et ça n'avait pas d'importance par
rapport à tout ce que le reste qui était
en train de dire donc ce qui est
étonnant c'est ce fait que Dimitri
piscov donc ce même porte-parole était
capable de dire que oui il y avait quand
même un problème de frontière et là on
nage dans le paradoxe le plus absolu
je ne sais pas vraiment comment
l'analyser si ce n'est que par le fait
que justement au plus haut sommet du
pouvoir russe on ne sait pas bien
comment gérer ces territoires ces
contrôles qui militairement ne sont pas
entièrement acquis et qui
constitutionnellement sont en train
d'arriver dans le giron de la Russie
c'est un c'est un paradoxe et d'ailleurs
il y avait un reportage formidable du
New York TIMS qui demandait à une femme
à Liman qui lui disait est-ce que vous
savez que vous avez pendant un jour vous
avez été russe et elle disait mais je le
sais même pas parce que nous à Lima on
est préoccupé par survivre et on n'est
pas préoccupé par écouter les discours
des uns et des autres pour savoir de
quel côté on est on est devenu donc vous
voyez c'est le flou le plus total
Gauthier on entretient ce flou c'est le
signe que finalement la Russie est
autant embarrassée que
qu'elle n'a qu'elle a provoqué
finalement ce jusqu'au-boutisme mais
elle ne sait pas aujourd'hui
faute d'une conquête facile comment
comment gérer la situation ne peut pas
se permettre non plus de que le
camoufler dure trop longtemps
oui alors en fixant des ambitions trop
élevées alors pour le camoufler on peut
se dire que tactiquement la nature du
discours de Poutine qui dit au fond
c'est pas l'Ukraine le problème c'est
l'Occident c'est pas mal de dire ça
parce que ça prouve on peut comprendre
que quand on s'attaque à l'Occident on
n'a pas gagné du jour au lendemain la
guerre et que là on peut être un peu
avoir de l'adversité ça fait partie du
jeu sur la délimitation des frontières
ça veut dire que je pense que que
l'opération de Poutine qui reposait sur
l'idée qu'il y a une césure
ethnolinguistique elle fonctionne pas et
que du coup on imagine si on voulait
être drôle mais c'est pas le peut-être
pas le moment mais que les Russes
posteraient le panneau frontières en
fonction des avancées de leur armée si
c'est pas trop dur à avaler s'ils ont
pas les yeux plus gros que le ventre on
peut pousser un peu plus loin le panneau
frontières si par contre ça va mal on le
rabaisse et on dit bah non on n'a pas
perdu on était en deçà c'est-à-dire que
si on en est là ça veut dire qu'il y a
vraiment des problèmes dans le caractère
opération celle de l'armée et que du
coup on se réserve la possibilité de
dire sous quel carglutie que ce soit que
ce territoire là non mais finalement on
le laisse à l'Ukraine les électeurs
brésiliens eux ont passé un autre sujet
vous l'aurez compris on fait mentir les
sondages hier il y aura bien un second
tour à l'élection présidentielle et le
résultat est beaucoup plus indécis qu'on
ne le pensait alors que Lula comptait
encore près de 15 points d'avance à la
veille du scrutin si l'on en croit bien
sûr les sondages et bien la marge et
trois fois moindre au final écouter les
résultats les réactions pardon des deux
finalistes
nous avons vaincu les mensonges des
sondages nous allons de l'avant tout est
remis à égalité maintenant nous allons
encore mieux montrer ce que l'on peut
faire pour le peuple brésilien
je pense que nous formerons une bonne
alliance pour gagner les élections
tout au long de cette campagne
nous étions en tête des sondages
d'opinion
de tous les instituts d'opinion
même ceux qui ne voulaient pas que l'on
gagne il disait que nous étions les
premiers
et j'ai toujours pensé que nous allions
gagner cette élection et je vais vous
dire nous sommes en train de gagner
cette élection
[Applaudissements]
que nous dit le résultat de ce premier
tour à bolsonaro comme Trump vous étiez
allé je crois pour le 1 il me semble aux
États-Unis sont des électrons
de la société américaine
écouter je crois que là on a 6 vraiment
un choc des titans de deux titans dans
une démocratie les plus les plus fortes
les plus puissantes les plus nombreuses
du monde et on voit bien que ces deux
hommes politiques sont les les deux
personnages les plus polarisés les plus
polarisants de tout le pays puisque pour
la gauche ma bolsonaro évidemment c'est
le diable c'est une menace dangereuse
justement pour la démocratie et pour la
droite c'est l'inverse la droite en loup
là un ex condamné pour corruption donc
et c'est entre ces deux personnes que le
peuple brésilien doit choisir donc j'ai
l'impression que
c'était ça va donner lieu en tout cas
dans les semaines à venir à une espèce
de chaud
télévisuel forcément puisqu'il va y
avoir des débats qui va faire beaucoup
d'audience mais je suis pas sûr que ça
met en valeur justement et que ça donne
envie forcément aux gens d'aller voter
c'est plus un spectacle finalement que
une vraie attente démocratique
un fascisme vendu aux puissances
d'argent et à l'agrobusiness contre un
marxiste bolivarien corrompu c'est un
peu comme ça que chaque camp se présente
si j'interprète que vous disiez Anne
ça vous inquiète vous Gauthier enfin
vous voyez des enseignements attirés de
ce scrutin et des conséquences aussi
pour la marge du monde juste une petite
réponse je suis pas d'accord avec Anne
sur le choc des titans d'accord bon sur
la route est un minable c'est affligeant
je voulais dire deux personnes très
populaires oui oui quand vous voyez ce
qu'il a fait c'est l'enseignement
bolsonaro et populaire malgré un bilan
qu'on nous présente
pris de m'excuser encore une fois ça
veut bien dire que contrairement par
exemple à ce que le Parti des
travailleurs a recommandé à analyser
dans ce cette élection dans cette
campagne ils ont dit mais finalement il
y a tellement de pauvres et il y en a
plus qu'avant de par le manga de
pensionnatsu que finalement logiquement
selon une analyse marxiste ça va se
reporter sur notre candidat et on va
gagner et ben non et c'est ça le
problème c'est que même des Brésiliens
qui sont la misère qui n'ont rien gagné
au contraire même qui ont perdu sous le
mandat pourquoi il vote quand même pour
lui parce que ce type là avec tout le
caractère minable qu'il peut avoir
fournit une nourriture symbolique
extraordinaire oui quelque chose qui
relève d'abord de la libération d'une
parole qu'elle parole c'est-à-dire de
pouvoir lancer des ordures et des
attaques sur toutes sortes de gens et ça
ça fait partie alors on dit oui mais ça
fait pas manger les os c'est vrai que ça
fait pas manger les gens mais ça lui
fait vibrer c'est du spectacle
et si vous ajoutez à cela le fait que
précisément quand on a eu la gauche de
Lula et qu'on a cru c'est ce que disait
tout le monde aussi bien à gauche que
même ceux qui étaient à droite disait
elle doit être exemplaire et la gauche
n'a pas été exemplaire et on lui fait
payer d'autant plus ça que quand on
s'appelle la gauche on doit être
exemplaire est-ce que Elula dans ce
premier tour c'est qu'il ne l'a pas été
on peut discuter des circonstances on
peut discuter aussi du fait qu'il avait
voulu contourner le Parlement alors que
celle qui a voulu être exemplaire c'est
fait
tout ça c'est intéressant mais on fait
payer aussi à cela à Lula cette forme de
valeur morale qu'il n'a pas respecté
qu'il n'a pas tenu par rapport à votre
en deux mots une élection sur les
symboles gratification symboliques
c'était essentiel dans le l'explication
pour comprendre ce premier tour
je ne sais pas je ne suis pas
brésilienne mais je pense que là on a
cette comparaison presque avec Trump et
puis votez pour être que des que des
personnalités comme bolsonaro comme
Trump comme Vladimir Poutine soit
populaire ce sont il y a matière à
réfléchir voilà mais oui absolument mais
on les a pas forcés à voter pour
bolsonaro merci beaucoup anniv merci
gauthierry winsky on se retrouve dans
trois minutes pour un nouveau journal
dans Paris